Wow
[Applause]
my brother's here yeah another [ __ ] face
work I told you throw down my [ __ ]
face don't stop I'm gonna throw this
[ __ ] scissors at you there hey hey
hey careful
let's introduce everybody babe all right
we got right here we got long toe long
long toe is kalila sister kwinda and she
has really one tell that's so abnormally
long that I'm thinking about calling the
Guinness Book of World Records because
it is really a sight to see
anyway sit down go into work George's
yeah sit down we're gonna have a little
you know circling chair kind of thing
okay we got jenna is here jessica is
here we have Renzo get long toes on boy
boyfriend he's a cop so don't [ __ ] with
us yeah well you will go to prison we
got a little Stevie we be my brother and
that's that so I'm put the headphones on
long toe hurry up long toe okay so long
toe you've never been on this podcast
before right Oh once but then we didn't
have video yet at that size oh yeah yeah
yeah well welcome thank you
[Laughter]
something about long toe yeah yeah long
toe along with her boyfriend have they
both have listened to every single one
of our episodes yeah they were tiger
belly experts so we're gonna go ahead
and talk about our favourites maybe are
not so favorites but by doing so let's
not hurt anyone's feelings that's right
don't go Esther ku was terrible yeah she
annoyed everyone okay of your nothing
I'm not saying that that's the case I'm
saying gave you an example yeah her
voice is makes me [ __ ] go crazy once
again a body drop
my favorite guest yeah
Theo von people like a sea of on ya most
profound was probably Eddie last week
yeah that was great
and um Eric Stonestreet you like that
one too
he was just very candid you know yeah
yeah could you see him one way on screen
but didn't you write and it's um
you know bringing these people into my
home is difficult because a lot of these
guys are on two bedroom college
apartment but it's your college report
that is true long toe and then you know
what you get a [ __ ] point for that
that was a [ __ ] layup of a compliment
and what other what other highlights
were there for you who do you think has
the best chemistry with Bobby of areas
Eric yeah Eric ooh Eric great Eric
Griffin alt a black of course yeah he's
on the show something comes out of you
it's different it's it it's a different
you know why cuz there's a motion yeah
you guys know it's not he's not even
friends it's like an anger I don't know
when I when we talk to each other
sometimes I get a sore throat and I want
to take his [ __ ] black titties and
rip them off G but not in a friendly way
oh and a friend okay in a non-violent
way love behind it though you can tell
your love yeah like he's well he's the
only comic worried because Bobby I go
what a rattlesnake bit me in the [ __ ]
nut sack I need you to suck it out okay
if he had consumption so what do you
mean consumption sake let's tuberculosis
what do you do if they're tuberculosis
I'm eating like that right what is
consumption is what Irish people had
described to me went on something
respiratory disease and failure so what
it comes out what do I do you do the
plan so all this phlegm comes out one
way to help with the phlegm yeah to suck
the phlegm out of the nose any orifice
with my mouth yeah their mouth that's
really out of all the years of medicine
that's what they came up with back then
yeah back then let's say his nose you
know back back in like the little house
in the Prairie days yes
all right so we're in the 1700s mm-hmm
we're roommates in a log cabin in the
forest breathe you can't breathe I come
in I have a raccoon yeah I have a dead
raccoon I just haunted yeah and I come
in I go yo man I'm sorry there's all we
got to eat your breathing
what's the matter Eric wow you sound
Mongolian right yeah what do I do
I need you to do one thing only liar I
need you just suck the mucus out of my
nose well huh and you gotta clean the
plugs yeah yeah I probably go listen man
die and leave but he can't breathe he
wouldn't suck it out of his nose I don't
know I think he's an appetite if he was
skinnier eat maybe but for some reason
cuz he is kind of big that there's a
feels like there's more mucus I would do
that for my sister yeah I would Steve
what Steve Steve he's gone no Steve I'll
do it for NECA
right yeah Eric and consumption No yeah
but rattlesnake bite on the nutsack yes
for the story for the story yeah yeah
and what other highs and lows Cohen de I
mean long toe is a city job we have to
protect Bobby has a lot of um words of
wisdom okay what are you being life
it's a fantasy and when I have a bad day
I tell myself that fantasy life is an
illusion a fantasy life is an illusion
you know what kind of just says the rib
I really do believe that that life is a
fantasy and the reason being is um one
time I was talking to my friend Joseph
and he was like you know what I do I
wake up and I just imagine life as a
movie through my eyes it just makes
everything better all the experiences
you know I mean because it's just it is
what it is you know my friend Joseph
right you name
was just I call him Joseph because we're
we got a relationship oh my ghostess
when I go way back yeah Joseph Rogan
thanks Joseph Rogan thank you for that
portable phone but I've applied it in my
life that's all oh god it's just your
narcissism is just oh here's another
thing here's another thing I don't have
more narcissism than anyone else on
planet earth everyone is narcissistic
no but there's pathological narcissism
and that's what you have I don't have
pathological narcissism I just have
regular narcissism okay okay that's all
the way you just stood up right there
classic narcissist hear me roar
everybody listen be right my friend JJ
riot oh my friend JJ told me that I
don't have narcissism okay when I say JJ
I mean Judd Apatow I call him JJ what
are you gonna say bro hey bro I don't I
don't know JJ Abrams and see a
narcissist okay
I have audition for him yeah didn't get
it okay
start so I start right I love Star Trek
why did you audition for start trying ho
they'll never give me anything so that
those are your all so uh who's your
least favorite guy we don't know come on
I'm honestly yeah I mean if we were
gonna go there um Bryan Callen was my
least favorite he's funny
hardy-har-har funny but um you know what
like this why I can let her explain go
ahead it's I thought you were a
narcissist but he takes it to a
different level and I shot spire and I'm
just I'm just a little protective of my
sister so his the way he talked about
her like oh you know what you've got a
good one here as if like she wasn't
gonna be that
otherwise like yeah yeah the big and the
big em would misogyny is yeah it's so
very funny guy
very funny oh don't get me wrong was a
really fun podcast I I just that was my
least favorite out of everyone really
but sometimes people talk that way you
know like um my friend of he's not a
star okay Doug Davidoff okay when I was
dating Sarah Hyland a long long time ago
I go this is my girlfriend Sarah and he
goes what's up woman I kept calling her
a woman and I go that's he's closed he's
caused no it's not East Coast it's just
it's ignorant are you not a woman
yeah but the tone behind it about hey
woman yeah there you go see Wow what are
you looking at man renzo we gonna arrest
me I didn't commit any [ __ ] laws bro
you know when you walk into a room do it
as a civilian you're [ __ ] civilian all
right you're not a [ __ ] cop in this
room with your like I like your energy
right now like you're gonna arrest
everyone in the room we did not commit a
[ __ ] crime [ __ ]
you know what officer go [ __ ] yourself
thank you I always want to say that to a
police officer by the way all this TV
ladies here
[Music]